[Música]
y vamos a hablar de salud en directo
américa de france 24 ya está conmigo en
el estudio más romeros a la mar
bienvenidos nuevamente a este estudio
vamos a hablar de la relación que hay
entre las ciudades y la salud porque
vivir en las ciudades le pregunto mar es
mejor o peor para nuestra salud ahí
estamos en un dilema no si efectivamente
puede en verdad toda la respuesta está
en depende de cómo estén planeadas no la
creciente urbanización en lo que ha
hecho ha sido acrecentar una carga de
enfermedades no infecciosas por ejemplo
a raíz de la polución de la calidad del
aire y precisamente ayer pues una
publicación de the lancet de expertos de
la organización mundial de la salud lo
comentaba entonces vamos a hablar de
todo esto vamos a desgranar los detalles
de esta publicación también con el
profesor oscar franco profesor de salud
pública de la universidad de berna
doctor muy buenos días y bienvenidos de
nuevo a esta sección de salud de directo
américa cuéntenos los principales
factores en las grandes ciudades que
hacen que nos enfermemos
sin mar y en primer lugar esto no es
nada nuevo no es algo que sabemos que
las ciudades y la salud van de mano en
mano
podemos recordar por ejemplo las cloacas
romanas para poder manejar los los
residuos así como por ejemplo el impacto
que tuvo la epidemia de tuberculosis a
principios del siglo 20 del modernismo y
el trabajo por ejemplo de le corbusier
para poder adaptar de una manera mejor
la la construcción para la salud pública
de hecho los derechos humanos recogen en
el artículo 25 que todas las personas
tienen derecho a tener unas
circunstancias o un nivel de vida que
pueda proteger su bienestar y su salud y
también el de sus familiares sin embargo
en las últimas décadas hemos visto como
sinónimo de progreso al cemento ya los
automóviles ya hemos visto como las
ciudades han crecido se han expandido
sin planeación y se han ido acumulando
cada vez más y más y más una dependencia
en el automóvil y yo creo que es el
tráfico que produce esa contaminación no
solamente la polución ambiental sino
también auditiva que tiene uno de los
mayores impactos en la salud de la
población
ya lo que hemos visto es que en ciudades
muy densas en sociedades con muchísima
población hay un mayor aumento en el
consumo de dietas pobres de comidas
procesadas de comida rápida una vida más
sedentaria y esto lleva también a más
estrés a más obesidad presión arterial
alta y enfermedades cardiovasculares y
muerte prematura doctor ya me está
asustando un poco como estaba muy buen
día gracias por estar con nosotros
nuevamente aquí en salud qué medidas se
deberían tomar entonces para reducir la
polución en la ciudad es porque yo no sé
si ha pasado también usted marque pues
por ejemplo hablando de bogotá donde
estaba radicado france24 en español uno
sale a la calle hasta que no llegue a la
casa huele el smoke por todo lado no
efectivamente lo huele lo traga lo ve
todo lo siente
si son medidas que todos podemos tomar
en primer lugar no hay que depender
solamente de los políticos sin embargo
hay que escoger bien en la persona que
se vaya a votar que pueda proteger el
medio ambiente y ya en nuestras manos
está por ejemplo tomar más el transporte
del público
tratar de tomar la bicicleta salir a
caminar compartir el carro si se tiene
que tomar el cargo entonces compartirlo
también es importante las iniciativas
por ejemplo para comprar productos
locales o iniciativas de jardinería
urbana que pueden ayudar a mejorar en la
adquisición de productos que sean
mejores para el medio ambiente y también
importante no utilizar las bolsas de
plástico ya no vemos lo hemos dicho
muchas veces tratar de considerar
siempre tomar las decisiones siempre
basadas en nuestra salud y la salud del
planeta apagar las luces cuando no se
necesitan por ejemplo y son medias que
todos tenemos a mano y que podemos tomar
por supuesto doctor aunque también pues
más allá de las responsabilidades
individuales es importante también esa
responsabilidad que tienen los
gobernantes y también la industria y las
empresas no habremos momento de eso las
ciudades son un escenario de desigualdad
también y precisamente por y esto tiene
efectos en la movilidad en los diseños
urbanísticos cómo impacta esto en la
salud
si vemos una segregación en donde los
ricos viven en una parte de la ciudad y
las personas con menos recursos en otra
parte que se tienen que movilizar a
prestar servicios que requieren aquellos
que puedan tener más recursos
movilizaciones que pueden llevar unas 23
horas de un lugar a otro aumentando la
polución adicionalmente vemos como un
pobre diseño urbano puede llevar a unas
casas oa lugares de vivienda en que
pueda haber más tropiezo más estrés más
aislamiento y también una pobre
protección contra el calor o contra el
frío y eso lleva un mayor consumo de
energía voy a utilizar por ejemplo leña
para cocinar o para calentar la casa por
dentro con poca ventilación que sabemos
está relacionado con enfermedades
obstructivas pulmonares y con
enfermedades cardiovasculares es una
especie para las causas de muerte en el
mundo entonces vemos que el impacto que
tiene es muy grande de destruir muchos
puntos de vista marc doctor vámonos dos
años atrás bueno un poco más a marzo de
2020 cuando comenzó la pandemia de kobe
19 que impactó como todos lo vimos o con
gran dureza todas las grandes ciudades y
bueno todas las ciudades en el mundo y
elecciones doctor podemos extraer sobre
este tema que pasó específicamente
selecciones que ya sabíamos porque
sabíamos que vivir en condiciones de
hacinamiento llevaban mayor cantidad de
enfermedades infecciosas lo haríamos con
el problema que tuvimos con la
tuberculosis que necesitábamos mejor
ventilación también ya lo sabíamos sin
embargo como que olvidamos y pensamos
que ya no éramos vulnerables a esas
enfermedades infecciosas del alumno
hemos visto como el acceso a tener agua
en buenas condiciones es fundamental
entonces lo que no lo que debemos
recordar es que seguimos siendo
vulnerables a ver qué ocurren las
pandemias de hecho somos más vulnerables
en la medida en que las ciudades se van
haciendo cada vez más grandes más densas
y cada vez estamos más cerca uno del
otro y eso facilita la transmisión de
las enfermedades infecciosas doctor una
última pregunta rápidamente para
terminar y también mirando a futuro no
como es la ciudad ideal del futuro qué
es lo que tenemos que esperar y desear
una pregunta muy muy importante y muy
difícil yo creo que es esencial que las
ciudades planeen a largo plazo con un
concepto de sostenibilidad muchas veces
vemos muchos desarrollos urbanos que son
a corto plazo por para resolver
problemas de muy corto perspectiva yo
creo que es importante tener un buen
equilibrio entre lo que es la parte
socioeconómica ese progreso que tanto
queremos como con la parte del medio
ambiente y natural para poder proteger
nuestro planeta y ayudar a que las
personas sean estén más en contacto unas
con otras a evitar ese aislamiento y
tener ciudades más solidarias donde las
personas se pueden contribuir una a otra
para mejorar su vida y para poder
alcanzar su máximo potencial
pues doctor muchísimas gracias como
siempre por su tiempo por acompañarnos
aquí en salud de directo américa gracias
mar también por acompañarnos la dueña de
esta sección de salud nosotros pasamos a
saludar a nuestro segundo invitado del
día gracias mar y doctor